[Music]
are you kidding
let's go
so
is
foreign
[Music]
it is the very first and the very last
you ever won the game against me
i remember
the game which went with the similar
scenario came between michael adams and
lanier dominguez
where lanier was winning
lanier was winning pot
and switla blunders the rook
and he plunders the rook and
and he resigns wow so um yeah that is
this is well this is well crazy seconds
i mean it was 40 seconds for sweat line
six seconds for karjakin only yeah
and
well no
i mean nothing left for them that's
that's absolute if king takes then the
rook rook comes down mate rook check oh
that looks
like it looks busted it looks as if he's
going to be made it is a nun where can
he go he's backed his king up queen
check that's got to be it surely it's
mate
why can't he just take the he can take
the rook in the corner what is queen
queen
are we missing something queen takes
rook in the corner it's checkmate and he
doesn't see it and he has not he's
missed it unbelievable that is
astonishing that a grand master of
evangelics
and now the night has come back and it's
now he's got 40 seconds oh under the
time pressure he's running with his king
this is unbelievable this almost unheard
of in a chess game
[Applause]
film
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you and congratulations once again
we will invite the winners of the blitz
chess championship to the stage now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fascinating match from that round though
was the 63 year old victor korchnoy
against vasilia vineshuk now if you look
here
evan chuck has a queen a knight against
coach noise king but ivan shook has no
time whatsoever to check mate so there's
a big rush here this is what speed chess
is all about eventually closing in for
the kill and there he goes bang
checkmate and courchnoy can't believe
he's shaking the clock he thinks he's
vendrick's run out of time but no
he made it
and coach noy completely disgusted at
the end
um
so please well i'm
still wondering if mr ronan could
elaborate what he means by
doing your best again obviously
doing your best means doing your best i
don't know why you don't understand
english
yeah okay so thank you very much for all
comments thank you for coming for the
press conference
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i don't think it's the best game but
it's the most effective
for the public congratulations thank you
yes it's already new year in my country
magnus carlsen took suddenly what
i don't believe he blundered
what what what what is his move
what is knight e6
what's idea knight c5 maybe
some tactic but what about a3
what he missed
my looks he missed it something
yes my face not happy miss it
and now he seems he misses remove i
don't even guess what he missed it
some big blunder for world such player
like magnus scarfs and rook b6 he missed
it
very easy
attack for two pieces [ __ ] i don't
know it's called [ __ ] on pin yes
two pieces he lost look his face unhappy
yes this is a
significant moment in game what to play
how to stop announce
unbelievable unbelievable luck for
vishwanathan and now he has chance to
became
leader of this tournament take it off
take two pawns up
technically winning he's just exchanging
pieces now it's all over put your keys
what's the queen takes g4
what's he overlooked
this is incredible the queen on g4
attacking the rook on c8 now what
black's queen is attacked on e3 what
should have played the second queen the
black queen moves back queen czech kings
queens
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and
some of it would suggest that it's
repairable
that black doesn't actually have to get
the position he got after move 25 and
there are ways to improve along the way
and some of those that's interesting
sorry i was
he's not sleeping no he's obviously not
sleeping but uh
well
a bit strange
no i mean it's it's okay but
uh and now it's quite clear that he was
just thinking but you know the first
that very first frame
startled me
oh
rook takes b7 is a possibility where
white wins that yeah look at v7 white
with a pawn like this
it's an illegal move knight e3 it's
incredible i mean what has happened
what has happened a carson loss in this
case i'm not sure
not thinking i think this is
unbelievable he's almost spent a minute
a minute 20 of his time
for four moves it's incredible the
uncertainty of this strong player he
clearly is a bit off form he better get
back in for him or he's going to be out
of this competition he's under four
minutes now it's crazy
you make a move make a move
madness come on this is this is
unbelievable this this is shocking i i'm
stunned to see it he's thinking this
long on on on this the fourth move of
the chess game
analyzing what i do not know but a
smearing has successfully thrown him off
and now he's used a minute and 30
seconds
to think about four moves this is
completely ridiculous he's putting
himself into a deep deep hole
yeah i mean this this simple recapture
of the pawn by white is a little bit
unusual normally you attack this knight
first having said that the position is
fairly simple what is vichy doing
finally made a move i mean could it
could it have been that dramatic oh but
look at that position the pieces oh and
he thumped that rope down with authority
and bam he's ripped off all the extra
points he's just got a passport and look
at him make a minute look like a year
he's ripped another point off the board